FIGURE IT OUT.
TO DAGEN’S POINT, $1,000,
THEY’RE GOING TO NEED MORE THAN
THAT.
>> Juan: I AGREE.
GREG.
>> Greg: TO THE MONOLOGUE.
WE LOOK AT SMALL THINGS IS
TRIVIAL BUT IN REALITY THE
THINGS WE IGNORE COME BACK TO
HAUNT US.
LOOK AT ME.
I WAS ONCE A SMALL THING MYSELF.
STILL DOWN.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE, SCIENTIFIC
PAPER PREDICTED THE PRESENCE OF
STARS-LIKE VIRUSES AND BATS
TOGETHER WITH THE PROCESS OF
EATING THEM IS A TIME BOMB.
THAT WARNING WAS FROM 2007.
NOW A WARNING FROM ME 2014.
IN MY BOOK ON PAGE 136, I WARNED
READERS THAT REUSABLE SHOPPING
BAGS, ONE STUDY LINKED THEM TO A
46% INCREASE IN DEATHS FROM
FOODBORNE ILLNESSES.
THEY RAISE THE RISK BY HARBORING
VIRUSES I COULD GO FROM YOUR BAG
TO THE FOOD YOU SHARE WITH YOUR
FAMILY.
REUSABLE FEED BAGS MIGHT’VE
KILLED MILLIONS OF PIGLETS SEVEN
YEARS AGO BY SPREADING A NOVEL
SWINE VIRUS.
OTHER RESEARCH AMONG HUMANS
SHOWS HOW VIRUS IS SPREAD WITH
SIMILAR BAGS, MAKING PEOPLE SICK
SICK.
SO WHY IS THIS IMPORTANT?
ESTATES BAN PLASTIC BAGS, YOU’RE
SUPPOSED TO RELY ON REASONABLE
WHICH IN NO TIME LIKE THIS AIN’T
GOOD.
STEER CLEAR OF CONTAMINATED
SURFACES YET WE CARRY ONE TO
STORES, SCHOOLS, WORKPLACES AND
PUT OUR FOOD IN IT.
IT MAKES SENSE TO POSTPONE THESE
BANDS.
WE ARE POSTPONING ANYTHING ELSE.
IT’S A VECTOR THAT WE CAN EASILY
CONTROL.
HERE’S THE GOOD NEWS.
WE AREN’T RUNNING OUT OF FOOD
AND WE PROBABLY WON’T.
THE BAD NEWS, THOSE BAGS THAT
YOU PUT THAT FOOD AND AREN’T
HELPING.
SOME VIRUSES SPREAD THROUGH GOOD
INTENTIONS GONE BAD.
THE BEST INTENTION NOW IS TO ASK
FOR SINGLE-USE BAGS, PLASTIC OR
PAPER.
DANA, MY WIFE COMES HOME.
SHE’S GOT THE MASK ON BECAUSE WE
ROLE-PLAY.
>> [LAUGHS]
>> Greg: SHE IS VERY HEALTHY.
SHE DOES ALL THE HAND WASHING
AND SHE YELLS AT ME TO TAKE MY
SHOES OFF.
BUT SHE’S HOLDING THE BAGS, THE
REUSABLE BAGS WITH PRODUCE IN
THEM.
I THINK WE THINK THIS IS A GOOD
MOVE.
BUT IT’S NOT.
>> Dana: THERE IS CONCERN
ABOUT PLASTICS IN THE OCEAN.
THAT IS A CONCERN.
YOUR BOOK POINTED IT OUT.
OTHERS HAVE POINTED OUT.
I GET PLASTIC ANXIETY AS WELL.
WATER BOTTLES AND THINGS LIKE
THAT.
THE POINT ABOUT THE BAGS AND
CARRYING THINGS AROUND AND
EVERYTHING, WE KNOW THAT IT
CAUSES MORE PROBLEMS.
RETHINKING SOME OF THESE THINGS,
IT’S NOT TOO LATE.
YOU CAN DO THIS.
TURN BACK THINGS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS SHOWN.
ONE OF THE THINGS THEY DID, THEY
STOPPED ENDING REGULATIONS THAT
DIDN’T MAKE SENSE IN THE FIRST
PLACE WHICH WAS NOW DOCTORS CAN
WORK ACROSS STATE LINES.
HOW ABOUT TELEMEDICINE.
THERE WERE REGULATIONS AGAINST
SOME OF THAT.
BY GETTING GOVERNMENT TO GET OUT
OF THE WAY, YOU ALLOW MORE
COMPETITION.
MY HOPE IS THAT THERE WILL BE
SUPER SMART PEOPLE OUT THERE,
MAYBE LIKE REAGAN THEY ARE ON
THE COUCH, YOUR NIECE LEARNING
GUITAR.
MAYBE SHE WILL HAVE THIS AMAZING
INTERNET IDEA TO COME UP WITH
THE PRODUCT AND SOLUTION --
INNOVATIVE IDEA TO COME UP WITH
BY A BIODEGRADABLE PLASTICS.
>> Greg: THE PROBLEM IS THAT
WE NEED TO RELY AND PEOPLE LIKE
ME TO WASH MY BAGS.
SOMETIMES I WEAR THE SAME GYM
SHIRT THREE DAYS IN A ROW.
I DRIED OUT ON THE SHOWER.
SO I’M GOING TO DO THAT.
PEOPLE GRABBED HER BAG AND THEY
JUST GO TO THE PLACE.
THAT’S THE PROBLEM.
YOU HAVE TO WASH THIS BAG EVERY
DAY WHICH IS WORSE FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT BECAUSE OF THE
CHEMICALS WERE USING.
I READ THAT SOMEWHERE.
>> Jesse: I WANT TO SAY
SOMETHING FUNNY ABOUT YOUR
ROLE-PLAY COMMENT.
I’M NOT GOING TO SAY IT.
I THINK IT’S SMARTER IF I BITE
MY TONGUE.
>> Dana: YOU CAN’T HOLD MY
HAND.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: I AM SOCIAL
DISTANCING MYSELF FROM GAFFES.
LIKE YOU SAID, GOOD INTENTIONS
AND THEN SOMETIMES IT BACKFIRES.
THEY SAID YOU DON’T WANT TO
CLEAR THE UNDERBRUSH OUT OF
THESE FORESTS BECAUSE IT’S BAD.
THEN YOU HAVE WILDFIRES.
RAISE THE MINIMUM WAGE.
THEN THEY FIRE HALF THE
WAITRESSES.
SOMETIMES THESE THINGS GO THE
WRONG WAY.
I USED TO MAKE FUN OF PEOPLE,
LIKE GERMAPHOBE’S.
JERRY SEINFELD.
HOW MANY EPISODES ON SEINFELD
DID THEY MAKE FUN OF HIS FEAR OF
GERMS?
KRAMER AND INSTALLING THE
GARBAGE DISPOSAL IN THE SHOWER
AND MAKING JERRY A SALAD OR
ELAINE SNEEZES ON THE PASTA
PRIMAVERA AND GETS THE NBC
EXECUTIVE SICK.
OR JERRY CATCHES THE CHEF NOT
WASHING HIS HANDS WHEN HE COMES
OUT OF THE BATHROOM.
YOU’RE SAYING IT’S FUNNY BUT NOW
YOU LOOK BACK AND YOU SAY JERRY
WAS RIGHT.
THIS WHOLE TIME.
WE NEED TO REEVALUATE EVERYTHING
WE’VE BEEN DOING.
AFTER WE BEAT THIS THING, WE ARE
GOING TO LOOK BACK AND SAY DO WE
NEED TO START HAVING MORE PEOPLE
WORK FOR -- REMOTELY.
WHY ARE WE LIVING ON TOP OF EACH
OTHER IN CITIES?
THE HANDSHAKE.
IS IT AN OUTMODED CONCEPT IN
THIS COUNTRY?
WE ARE OVERLY RELIANT ON CHINA.
THESE THINGS ARE GOING TO BE
REEVALUATED.
A >> Greg: DAGEN, SHOULD THEY
DELAY THE BAN?
>> Dagen: WE SHOULDN’T HAVE IT
IT.
WHO’S MAKING THESE DECISIONS
ABOUT BANNING PLASTIC BAGS?
YOU KNOW SOME GUY SAYING LET’S
TO GET TO THE OIL AND CHEMICAL
COMPANIES.
IT’S NOT BASED ON RESEARCH.
AS YOU POINTED OUT, GOES BACK
MORE THAN A DECADE KNOWING THAT
THESE BAGS AREN’T SANITARY.
I BANNED THE HANDSHAKE A WHILE
AGO.
1 OUT OF 20 DUDES WHO WANT TO
SHAKE YOUR HAND DO THAT WEIRD
TICKLE THING WHICH IS CREEPY.
GREG, TWO WORDS.
DARTH VADER.
>> Greg: THE GOOD NEWS IS THE
PROBLEM HERE ISN’T FOOD.
I THINK WE ARE GOING TO DO OKAY
IN THIS INDUSTRY.
IT’S BAGS.
HOW DO YOU FEEL?
SHOULD THE BAN BE TEMPORARILY
SUSPENDED?
>> Juan: YEAH.
IF YOU CAN IDENTIFY IT AS A
SOURCE OF SPREADING THE VIRUS, I
WOULD.
I THINK WHAT YOU SAID DESCRIBING
IT TO THE AUDIENCE, EVENT GETS
DIRTY, FILLED UP WITH MICROBES,
YOU DON’T KNOW WHAT’S IN IT.
HE SAID THAT IT KILLED PIGLETS.
THAT’S REAL.
I THINK IT’S NOT A REASON TO SAY
LET’S GIVE UP ON THIS IDEA.
I THINK YOU CAN LOOK UP IN THE
TREES IN CENTRAL PARK OR ANY
PART IN THIS COUNTRY AND YOU SEE
PLASTIC BAGS AND YOU KNOW ABOUT
THE OCEAN.
I THINK COMING UP WITH
BIODEGRADABLE SUBSTANCES IS A
GOOD IDEA.
I DON’T WANT TO USE THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GO BACK ON LOTS
OF OUR EFFORTS IN TERMS OF
MAKING SURE THE ENVIRONMENT, THE
FACT THAT WE SEE CLIMATES
RISING.
WE CAN’T GIVE UP THEIR WE HAVE
TO STAY FOCUSED ON WHAT WE ARE
ALREADY DOING, MAKE IT BETTER.
DON’T ALLOW THAT TO COMMUNICATE
THAT TERRIBLE DISEASE.
TODAY I WAS SHOCKED, 475 PEOPLE
DIED IN ONE DAY TODAY IN ITALY.